[Music]
and welcome back to careful boys we have
with us mr walter hong ladies and
gentlemen
rams fanatic
rams fanatic oh that's right look at
your uh
almost as if you were there huh almost
oh how did you guys
did you know how did you know yeah oh
[ __ ]
we saw you on tv it's amazing you think
you'll go to another one now um dude so
next one's in arizona and i'm already
getting like offers to get like you know
cheaper tickets that's still like 20
grand uh yeah are the rams you think the
rams are gonna make it next year it's
you know unless you're the patriots like
bill belichick thomas it is very
unlikely to do two years yeah two years
in a row it's very unlikely because
other teams have coaches too yeah and
they're figured out they're they're
figuring out what's going on and then
our coaches have to like figure out
other things to do why is the patriots
so dominant just because tom brady and
the brady and village belichick do you
think do you think belichick is a actual
cheater
do you think these allegations are true
about him i think so oh god who was it
wife cheater or the sports games all of
it yeah
deflating the ball cheaters which barber
said it
may have been tiki barber he's like
every year there's a limit of what
supplements we can take and then the
next year it becomes more even strict
even more strict
so everyone does right up to that line
yeah and so i believe coaches probably
do that too they push that line right
they do everything they can right to
that line like hey go ahead just just
sit there and film and then someone asks
you just say you're filming us that's
what makes a good coach man no way in
line yeah some people can cross the line
so i one of my buddies the strength and
conditioning coach for a couple nba
basketball players during the piss
testing uh everyone goes a piss test
right and then they go oh lebron their
turn nicole's iphone called me and he
just walks out and it takes the phone
call it doesn't have to come back in are
you wow
i say [ __ ] about lebron james play for
the cavs and also the lakers but if
anyone's going to be on peds that's
probably what's adults dude that dude is
like he's stuck i didn't say [ __ ] about
stuff i don't know what you're talking
about lebron lebron
does all that stuff make you look like
younger because like he looks the same
now do you see his hairline though
oh yeah that's just that's just like
right here black don't crack you know
they just they just always look young
yeah
but then when he was 17 he looked like a
poor man yeah he already looked forward
to this what was the name the situation
on mtv jersey shore they had that like
old man face yeah yeah that's true
yeah lebron does have an old man yeah
he's finally growing into it that
hairline also makes a big difference
he's just shaving i don't know why he
just don't shave it
he has a dream he's also tall enough
where most people can't see it right
then
then you're like oh wait that looks like
an alfalfa farm that's like going
through a drought
but then mark marketing's tough too
because clyde drexler he had a receding
header line and most people don't know
who he is black people know who he is
but he was a great basketball player but
he had that old man hairline
that's funny that i never thought of
that as a hack for baldness just be
taller yeah yeah that's true
are you bald no mugsy bones on the other
hand gotta get keeps you good yeah
yeah lebron gotta get keeps
i don't bring yourself i'm surprised
keeps doesn't try to like head out and
try to get him like
what you think you think he'd be a hell
insulted though they can't know when
they're offering he would go why why are
you coming to me yeah wasn't diddy
promoting like proactive he goes yeah my
god [ __ ] acne
that's diddy though you see how many
things he hoes out for
it's like you wanna you like you wanna
fix your acne and drink this vodka
he needs to didn't he buy his son at
maybach i'm not surprised he's like 16
year old bottom of a baby what father
hasn't
yeah bart's gonna buy tycoon right now
for myself
so wait are you married walter no
i gotta bring that up man that's that's
my shirt i wanted to stab you right
before i asked this next question how
many you've been in a lot of
relationships
um relationships is a strong word
uh a lot of flings situations okay good
out of the situations we've all been in
in the past what is the most you've ever
changed for a woman
whoa most you ever change what do you
mean by change like physically either
anything the most different you've ever
acted appeared been i remember in
eighth grade junior high
uh i think we all do these simp moves
where
when you're talking to a girl
and you just want to have common
interests right because it's so exciting
to be like oh you like that i like that
[ __ ] too right so when you're on a
conversation
any hobby that she had i would be like
oh what a coincidence we are so
i [ __ ] love that much felicity too
i love felicity this one was like
clarissa the teenage witch or like
sabrina
explains it all
maybe where you grew up
clarissa you think about clarissa from
your eighth grade class or some [ __ ]
because there were like three of them
it's it's rachel the vampire slayer
did you grow up in the philippines
they had bootleg version
oh that's rachel she's the slayer
we don't have the puppy but we have the
rachel poppy
kalista
no but i saw myself like on the phone
and just being like oh my god that's so
cool like we're you know i didn't like
he used to lie about having the same
hobbies i didn't like i don't know i
just wanted to be liked you know so you
lied
i didn't lie i did the same thing when i
was in high school like uh tiff was
reading this book called the lovely
bones
and you were like i too am a serial
killer yeah i was like yeah i know how
to kill people too is that like a
romantic novel i don't know what you
said you were reading it too oh yeah she
was reading it and she's like you should
read it with me i was like i'm gonna
read that [ __ ] are you gonna read it
with it
at the same time and [ __ ] yeah there's a
movie so so get this get this this is so
she goes yeah you know like and this is
when i was like courting her and she's
like we should read the book and i was
like all right we'll read it together
and then she was like oh have you have
you been reading i was like yeah totally
like your boy is reading this book
front to back
like yeah and i was like oh yeah
i'm [ __ ] i'm reading all the [ __ ]
things i've read about every bone
already yeah yeah they're all lovely and
then and then like she didn't realize
that i didn't read the book at all
and we ended up watching the movie
together afterwards and you were like
shocked throughout the movie whoa
she dies
i was like yo mark wahlberg is in this
you know all you have to say all you
have to say is like
the book was better yeah
you did read it
but like that's what she said and i just
let her do all the talking about it
because she was like yeah i didn't like
the the movie it just wasn't as good and
i was like yeah that's what i thought
too and it wasn't until like years later
like as we're adults probably like eight
years later i was like you know babe i
never read a lovely book
oh my god you should have said you
should have saved that for your [ __ ]
honeymoon night you'd be like
and she just was like oh all right
she didn't give a [ __ ]
it was just funny it was just funny that
like oh yeah of course you're a little
[ __ ] bitch-ass into reading it of
course the thing the sole thing that our
relationship is founded on his face
you know what that means that you should
just continue lying to her because she's
just gonna be like okay that's cool
she's like yeah all right whatever i
like her i lie to her about like
complicit eating pork and stuff i'll
like sneak her pork oh that's not pork
and she'd be like oh okay it's a bacon
burger yeah i mean that's how i do it
nowadays it's a beef bacon it's beef
bacon he's making the rare pig cow
hybrid hitler anyone have anything worse
than that or is that as bad as guests
i i don't compromise myself you don't
compromise at all nothing that's
probably why i've never been in a
relationship
i'm too honest
every time they ask have you read the
lovely bones hell no
i read that dumb ass book
stanley two
what's the what's the like closest that
was about to get into a relationship
you're like oh man it's gonna make me
change [ __ ] that um
i was in relationship with this one girl
where uh
first day of the relationship like like
we we said like we're going to be like
seriously yeah she goes we need to talk
i'm thinking
it's the first person already what could
i have done in the first day you already
assume you're in trouble yeah because
you know we need to talk that's like
that's universal code it doesn't matter
what language you say it in something's
wrong yeah and then she goes
like the texting what's going on with
that i'm like what do you mean
like you know people just text
yeah you need to call me
so i was like okay
oh yeah okay cool you know like it's not
a big deal so the next day i call
instead of text that's why you call me
yeah and then no and then she she calls
me back like a couple hours later she
goes we need to talk
oh dude you can't use that that many
times man okay you're getting too much
anxiety
right and this isn't day 10
or like a month later
this is day two i'm like what could i
have done you
yeah we didn't even see each other like
physically see each other
and then she goes hey when you call and
then don't leave a message what does
that mean i'm like oh it just means you
call back when you have a chance you
know because i'm assuming you're busy
yeah no you need to leave a message is
this person from 1963 like
i was like all right that's cool and
then
send a pigeon
send the pigeon you didn't leave a
message
set a western union telegram why didn't
you send the white pigeon like i don't
know you know and so the third day i
forgot what it was that that i did but
she goes we need to talk i go yes we
need to talk wow
and and then that was it you're just
like what did she want to talk about i
don't remember what it was but it was
something similar on the same level of
the you didn't send the email yeah after
the voicemail and so i was like yeah no
we need to talk i also feel like in this
generation though they would actually
praise her like she's set in her
boundaries yeah she knows i don't know
about that
it sounds a little crazy yeah they're
setting the boundaries though that's
great you want to do that that's great
but then at the same time they want to
do love me for me
at the same time they don't want to
change that's all but they want to
change you exactly they're okay with you
changing and not you not sending your
setting your boundaries because if you
set your boundaries you're being mean
yeah and that's not fair who the [ __ ]
scolds you after the first day of being
with them right yeah that's and i just i
just couldn't because then me the way i
am is i start thinking in the future so
i'm thinking five years from now this is
gonna be like ten years from now it's
gonna be like like we need to talk this
is
1275 times that we needed to talk
you keep putting a running tally yeah
why are you with me like that's a panic
attack if you hear that too many times
yeah
but then or it'll get to a point where
you're like i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
okay i'm not wired that way but i'm sure
after like you know the 900th time i'll
be like you know what i don't it's gonna
wear you down you know i remember in my
20s right like me and my buddies um we
would sell illegal substances
like what cuban cigars
piranhas and drugs like dvds of clarissa
the teenage witch
bootleg dvds of rachel the vampire
slayer all right
i remember though okay so one of our one
of our buddies he went to prison and he
came out right
and then we're just like okay let's get
back to business and then he's like
actually
i'm going to school and we're like so
after school you can't [ __ ] do this
and he goes nah like i talked to my girl
and like i'm out and i was like your
girl and we were laughing and we're just
like you're a little [ __ ] girl change
you you [ __ ] right and then he goes off
becomes successful great human being and
i'm sitting here in my late 20s like oh
dude he made the right choice i'm so
glad
i'm so glad he didn't turn around and
say you know what [ __ ] that i listen to
no girl because he's still with the same
girl yes wow
i do i do remember when you're like with
your boys
the first one that wants to start
backing out you're like mother [ __ ]
you [ __ ] ass [ __ ] yeah it's
almost like they're backstabbing you
yeah even though they're better in their
life they're bettering their lives
you're supposed to go off the cliff
together it could still be both it could
still be a backstab but i could put that
context into other time-wasting things
that guys like to do together right and
it's like women probably have this
long-term thinking of hey we need to
like save money have children
you got to stop [ __ ] around with your
friends right but you're like 25 24 just
like man you don't know what you're
talking about i'm [ __ ] doing things
i'm gonna be a rapper or whatever it is
right
i remember in early college
like everyone would hang out every day
and i remember one of them was like
hey i think i'm gonna join the fire
academy and i'm like oh how often we're
gonna hang out then he goes
i'll probably only maybe like once a
week we're like once a week [ __ ] that
fire academy
that's so often in adult time yeah like
super often yeah we're lucky if we could
meet up once a week like in adult time
i'm like what i'm like nah dude i don't
know if you should choose it
i love how your [ __ ] can have such a
sway over the things you do solo yeah
yeah i love how 19 year old joe was like
i'm not gonna change for
nobody and then i'm looking back like
god dang you should have dude yeah
no it's like you know when you're young
like you have your crew and you're like
oh i'd be cool if we all lived in the
same cul-de-sac yeah oh yeah right now
that we're older we're like hey man i'll
see you next month you know because like
if they if they live next door to you
you don't want them knowing that you
know your kinks that come in and out of
your house every day you don't even know
hey i saw someone come into your house
and then someone came an hour later yeah
don't worry about it
why are you looking outside your window
walter got some wild kicks yeah i'm just
saying though you know hey richard
jefferson from the spurs and a great
basketball player he had this great
thing on tick that he goes don't kink
shame we say that here
yeah
well for me because if i say it's like
oh you're just trying to defend yourself
but if someone else says it it's like oh
someone else is defending me
and he played in the nba he's very an
authority
a successful authority said here's a
question for hasagawa let's say you meet
the girl of your dreams
super hot
everything you have a girlfriend i know
but let's imagine she doesn't exist yeah
you're single no he's saying the girl of
your dreams not your girlfriend
i felt the underlying joke sitting
underneath it i was like i'm gonna nip
this in the butt right here
i like where walter was going what if
she goes
she goes i like everything about you but
i just hate guns
no way
will you change guns i'm probably not
what if she goes but i love knives
i would be like what's the distinction
here like the [ __ ] ryan goes he's
like what's up
how's it girl
let me tell you let me tell you the
distinction it's the 30-foot rule
the amount of time it's going to take to
close the gap 30-foot rule
they changed it it used to be 25 feet
now it's 35 feet how many times 30 feet
what rule is this the amount of time it
takes to you know still run up and stab
you if you have a gun and i have a knife
right and um i'm beyond 30 feet
you can't shoot me you can't claim
self-defense but if i'm within 30 feet
you can claim self-defense by shooting
me because that means i have enough time
to get to you and stab me okay yeah but
i don't know what age group they
interviewed for 30 years that's all
25 is a lot there's some anonymities
that change that you got to be you got
to be fast like that means basically i
have my knife out
and you can't have your gun in your hand
it has to be holstered and then you can
pull it out but i'm i'm not gonna lie to
you
ten feet i'll be shot i i feel like like
you know so but also if you're hyped up
on coke like like that that that range
that range is fast like you watch like
shooting videos of like cops like
officer-involved shootings you see the
distance that they close you're like oh
that's that's not a lot of time oh yeah
i've seen cops where you know they're
literally like arresting the dude yeah
and then they turn to their partner and
they look back and support everybody oh
[ __ ]
i'm like what the hell is going on
the other thing with this rule is
who knows what 30 feet looks like yeah
yeah yeah like you know obviously you're
in tunnel vision with a yeah you're
trying to scare like honestly like if a
guy came at me with a knife and i had a
gun
and i shot him but he was like let's say
50 feet away or 40 feet away i'm not
gonna lie to you i'm gonna take a few
steps forward
just run the market and be like yo this
is where i was standing that's not
measurable ballistics wise is it
wherever you were standing you can well
well they'll probably depends how much
they care about the victim
or what color the victim was that's why
you pick up the casing and you throw it
over there
[Laughter]
so that's uncompromisable
guns for you is uncompromised she's a
dream girl she's everything it's just a
big part of my life like half of my work
is like let's say you and your girl get
married and then eventually she goes i'm
just uncomfortable having guns around
the house well we probably have to talk
about that before we get married
that's probably that's something that
you got to like hashtag so there's
non-negotiables for you guys i think now
there are i'll change everything for
when i was younger i would change a
bunch of [ __ ] i mean certain things are
like well it's just it's a big part of
like my my work and stuff too like half
of my like work is like involving like
some sort of like funny not speaking to
the heart dude you got to be like girl
with this gun
i could save our family
like you've definitely
like joe you've definitely gotten like
dating a girl from church have you ever
gotten more religious
no i try to corrupt the [ __ ] out of her
or did you use this the spiritual rape
thing we're like hey yeah let's pray
together let's pray together
what the [ __ ]
that's what they call it in the you know
sva communities they call it yeah like
when you're when you're trying to you
know fake using god yeah to get closer
to a girl oh that's what it's called
spiritual rape i thought it was like
let's pray
i thought it was like that that's just
regular race
you don't need the spiritual part of it
it's universal it's regular yeah
dude i think non-negotiable for me like
a deal breaker would be like you know
you know you want me to be happy you
know yes of course well i need to do
things that make me happy okay you know
cool i need to cheat on you to make me
happy i feel like those things would be
like deal breakers you know like where
their fundamentals go against your
fundamentals
unless it's like an open relationship
yeah but i could be open it could be
open yeah i mean if you and i were in
leadership it would be totally open
but like you know you guys gotta [ __ ]
other people yeah i hate sports but you
can watch hockey and that's it
that's hilarious
i hate sports i'd love to know what her
what her specific beef with all the
sports but not hot she's got reasons she
got a reason you wouldn't be able to
live off just a minute i did yeah i did
go out with a girl that i remember
getting tickets to the usc north
carolina uh game this is years ago
and
someone just goes i can't go here's
tickets they're free you know like hey
let's go
you didn't ask me
i literally just got them like there was
no time to ask you but let's go
i don't even like football
like no let's not go i think he dated a
lot of korean chicks it sounds like
how does he know these things
he can smell the bulgogi have you dated
a korean chick you know i could smell
the drama yeah the type of [ __ ] they say
they're already conspiring before they
even got with you dude it's yeah i just
and i was just and then you know me just
being like you know a regular dude at
that age because you know it's like like
teens early twenties
okay we're not gonna we don't need to go
no
like if it was now i'd be like okay well
is it cool if i go yeah like you know
i'll just go myself like i don't care if
i find someone to go cool
but yeah there's it's just if to answer
your question i don't know that's such a
it's a laughable moment for me um
to ban sports yeah
then replace she goes all right instead
of football games we're just gonna watch
amy schumer stand up oh no and then i
have to tell her well i don't watch
stand-up because you know it's what i do
i i don't watch it that's not what you
do not amy schumer's that's true i don't
know
[Laughter]
we hadn't sold ourselves i think i think
at that point though it wouldn't be a
dream girl anymore
i i think honestly it would be like a
because in my mind like i said i would
think five years ahead ten years ahead
and then it's like okay today
no more korean food
like from now on we're only gonna have
japanese and filipino food oh damn
that's kind of interesting combo just
get japanese food and add a lot of
spices and sesame oil and you got korean
food
are you trying to say we copied your
cuisine is that what you're trying to
say
we just took out the sesame oil that's
all we did
put on the side that's all it is
you